[Musique]
pour cette 13e édition de la Nuit
européenne des musées les équipements
culturels du département situés dans la
rue de Paris s'éclairent de projection
numérique trois musées ouvrent
gratuitement leurs portes cette nuit à
un public venu découvrir l'art sous
toutes ses formes je pense que c'est une
ambiance particulè le fait que ce soit
le soir bon là on a la chance de
bénéficier de de quelqu'un qui en plus
nous les œuvres et je trouve ça très
très intéressant du coup ça ça redonne
envie de de prendre un peu de temps et
d'aller dans les musées d'aller
apprécier les œuvres que font les les
artistes trois artistes s'approprient
les espaces extérieurs du musée
leéonderx de l'artotèque et du Muséum
d'Histoire Naturelle l'image accompagnée
de musique éveille la curiosité des
passant la nuit des musées attire
effectivement un public extrêmement
diversifié
qui ne vient pas
forcément au musée habituellement et
comme vous pouvez le voir c'est un
public très familial et au Muséum c'est
l'artiste plasticien Lionel
Lorette qui a
choisi de décliner la vie sous-marine en
accord et en harmonie avec les
expositions qui sont présenter les
monstres marins et les requins beaucoup
de visiteurs pour cette nuit numérique
et beaucoup porteront un regard neuf et
différent sur les musées historiques de
la réunion nous avons donc cette
nouveauté avec l'art visuel sur nos
musées qui est aussi une forme
d'accroche pour que les gens le voient
et et viennent à la rencontre des musées
puissent rentrer à l'intérieur et
découvrir les trésors que possèdent nos
musées à la
Réunion
[Musique]